no oh hell-oh stalagtite mites yeah
who did that hello everybody my name is
markiplier and welcome to my playthrough
the force now I've done something
unprecedented here for this game that a
lot of people been anticipating and
recommending I have actually studied up
on how to play the game I've spent an
hour practicing so that I know exactly
what I need to do and yet somehow you
guys know I'm still gonna screw it up
somehow I'm gonna mess everything up at
all yay so either way um this game was
announced about six months ago and a lot
of people were very very eager to play
it because it combined a lot of the
favorite aspects in a lot of game it is
a survival open-world sandbox you craft
your own stuff you craft your own
shelter you craft your own supplies
survival is completely up to you now
this is an early alpha build as it says
right there so there are a lot of things
that aren't completely implemented just
yet but either way this game is
incredibly fun from the practice that I
have done I can already say I would
recommend this to anybody anybody out
there who's a fan of this genre which
came up recently you know it's not
multiplayer so it's not quite like the
same as rust in seven days died and and
all those different crafting survival
horror games but if this game ever did
implement multiplayer I can't think of a
better one oh by the way there's a kid
here to your right that you need to be
very concerned for because he's your son
and I actually feel bad because I missed
the moment like I said I played it
are you doing
okay we're all crash-landing and dying
no my son it's he okay ah okay so I wish
I could have filmed my surprise to this
guy because I I honestly had no idea
what to expect I knew there were
monsters in this game but actually it
turns out the monsters are just people
they're just an indigenous tribe that
are in this forest that a plane crashed
into their whole city and they you know
hey you know maybe they might be
cannibals but hey we we intruded on them
it's really our fault here we're the
ones at fault
so either way plane crash guy took your
son you need to get him back but before
you do that you need to be able to
survive now the first mistake that I
made in this game and a lot of people
where I make the first time that they
play this with no introduction to the
game outside of what's going on here is
that they probably built a shelter right
away now there is a survival guide so
that you guys aren't completely lost and
I was completely lost and I didn't even
bother to check it the first time I
played it once again because I am dumb
so either way you start at whoo-hoo I
started out right by the lake where you
start out as completely random but you
need to be careful because you could be
right by a a tribal settlement here but
there fish in here I don't know how to
get fish because I've never even
bothered to get fish maybe I could spear
them with a stick and let me try
something you have an inventory system
and oh I didn't get a stick yet
whoopsies I'm an idiot so basically all
the materials that you need are in the
environment here if you need leaves you
just wow what the hell do I have in my
hand what do have a sharpened stick I'm
a fish where you fish where fish fishy
fishy fishy fishy get in my belly
there's a fizzy get on my stick
fuzzy fuzzy God one yes I knew I could I
only tried like 13 bajillion times for
that to work but hey it actually
happened so thank you guys for believing
in me I know that you believed in me and
I'm glad that I believed in you as well
so thank you everybody for your raucous
applause anyway so this seems like as
good a place as any to start out I
haven't seen any patrols now these
indigenous guys
they patrol around quite a bit so it can
be hard to actually avoid them but there
seems to be a nice valley in here whoa
hello I'm gonna kill you and then I'm
gonna get ya you rabbit blink ah
come on get the rabbit is right there
that was brother you die you I'm at it
yeah yeah gotcha did I get you I think I
got you now you're mine back thank you
yeah I'm getting food I'm getting food
everybody I'm a survival master okay
who's going actually much better this
spawn has been actually been quite good
to me because there's a body of water
with fish in it there are animals nearby
and I'm assuming that they're gonna be
berries in this wood chew but every time
that I've tried to set up a camp by the
plane I ended up dying because there
have been too many enemies I see him
over there okay I'm out I'm out I'm out
I'll come back here later if I need to
get something temporarily but then
there's no way I'm sitting at my camp
e'er it is not a good idea to set up
camp where there are patrols because
they will screw up your entire life
they'll call the rest of the tribe and
they'll get over here and they'll just
destroy everything what is that I've
never seen this before
there's a lot I've been playing this
game for an hour and by the way I I may
mention it but I really thoroughly enjoy
this game but man there's not a lot that
I've seen this island is enormous
there's so much more to this everything
on the island is also interactable I
don't know if I mentioned that you can
cut down these things for leaves and
sticks whatever you need you need a lot
of leaves and sticks to be able to get
through some of them don't give you
anything like there's multicolored
plants out there but I don't know what
they do I chop them down but you can't
get anything from I'm assuming that
because it's an early development it
needs more time on the hello birdie hey
who are you telling me this is a safe
place for me to build my camp you did
what you're telling me are you telling
me that I'm gonna die anyway okay so
there's basic stuff this is a Survival
Guide and it's vile it's like you're a
recipe book for building all your things
now I have managed to build anything
besides a hunting shelter because the
log cabin takes literally eighty two
logs and you'll see why in a little
why that is very problematic well these
birds are here so I'm gonna assume that
it's relatively safe I have nothing to
base that off of but so you gather up
stuff in your backpack and they need to
slam them into your building what you're
gonna do and birds provide feathers by
the way but I don't know what I can
build with feathers like I said there's
a lot of things that are not yet
implemented so I don't know exactly if I
am just either missing them myself or if
they are not ready so I am going to keep
playing for your guys's entertainment
now this hunting cabin is just basically
a temporary shelter and what it needs
now is logs and you can get logs if you
guessed it straight from cutting down
the frickin trees this is really cool
guys the entire environment is totally
interactable and also when it gets night
it's utterly terrifying because I have
no idea how to survive night I've yet to
survive one night on my own but let's
see if we can change my luck in that
regard
yay now it's actually kind of tedious to
get logs because but actually very
impressive because watch this UN's like
god damn it you have to be very finicky
about how you're cutting this thing
because sometimes it won't decide that
it wants to give you the log that you're
cutting down and timber oh no no no no
not much other Oh
actually that makes it much easier
because I'm the log to go right to it
and looking look at look at how badass I
am I carry two logs I can sprint at full
speed pom pom now each tree oh where do
they go okay there's another log I think
they give four logs a piece standard no
matter what but I'm not exactly sure
maybe these thinner trees give less I
don't know they all seem to take the
same amount time to cut down I have no
data on that I cannot confirm that I'm
low energy I need to eat or sleep my
stomach is actually full so I'm doing
okay on food what I need to do now is I
need to sleep bye bye and also it gives
the sound before it actually hits the
ground but that's besides the point once
again an alpha this game is actually
pretty impressive for being an alpha and
when the tree lands it tosses the logs
everywhere I don't know where the other
log go where to go there it is sometimes
it can be hard to pick it apart even if
they do glow but at night that glowing
is a godsend there's no way
you could find what you need if there
was not that glow so the way yeah we
built our first shelter everybody and
you guys may want me to sleep because
sleeping saves your game but sleeping
also turns it tonight and I do not one
night it and oh my god I almost miss
that guy
hello you want to give me your skin
hello thank you
yep no no no I go what is that it do
they get it uh can't carry anymore raw
lizards well then I'll just have to cook
some up Thank You birdies birdies
they're so adorable I don't see any guys
patrolling around so I think I'm okay if
they haven't found me by now that
usually means that I'm good but then
again this is just a hunting cabin I can
I can move location very quickly because
this thing is easy to set up but for now
I'm gonna build another fire and I'm not
gonna get build a crappy one that tells
me in the tutorial I'm actually gonna
build a legitimate fire with rocks and
whatnot so to do that any more rocks so
I gotta go exploring but befo god I'm
tired I need some rest but I don't want
to be night I don't even have a fire set
up so we're just gonna walk around
because there's no God I don't wanna you
guys don't even know you know about it
isn't night years Oh No
as I was GERD I'm kind of scared I know
that's good but either way it's not
gonna take much to get rocks I don't
know if you can no no no I didn't think
so
project breakup my axe to get rocks if I
actually could hit him out of that my
god this is cool I I can't even describe
my feeling for right now you know in a
not so weird sense this game reminds me
a lot of Minecraft and I mean obviously
it's crafting you get your research from
the environment
got a minute [ __ ] here you can only
carry 5 rocks at a time I think so but
it's just it's really got captures that
sense of wonder I'm in a world where
everything is under my control
and I can literally do whatever the hell
I want that is that's really cool to me
it's cool that there's a there's an
ability to have all of this in a actual
game that looks you know not like the
top top graphics but this still looks
really good I mean look at all that
foliage once again I have a good
computer but hey it's not so bad okay so
now it's the dead of night I don't even
think that's a sunrise I think
as a sunset so if I sleep one more time
I will ah there it is okay so I slept
twice you can sleep as many times as you
want in a row I think that is sunrise I
completely avoided the night cycle by
the way guys and and you guys will be
glad for me to do that because it's bad
it's bad news bears we doing let me hang
on I got it there's one thing that I
haven't been able to figure out is how
to cook these things but let's I can't I
can't assume that it's much different
from just lighting up this fire right
here and also don't stand in the fire I
stood in the fire and it did not turn
out well for me
it burned real bad so anyway what I'm
gonna do is I'm gonna take this and I'm
gonna try to cook it oh that's how you
do it that's awesome I'm cooking up a
lizard can I cook up a fish you can get
a moldable thing towards man learn you
animal bastards feed me with your flesh
okay although uh I don't know why that
reminded me of this one interesting
thing I found in the Survival Guide
right oh it's not here why is it not
here ah there it is you could build
effigies I don't know why I'm assuming
that's after you go delusional and you
lose your mind and you're unable to
comprehend everything you're doing but
you can literally build effigies I don't
think I can right now and I don't think
I want to but oh my god you can but
either way you can also build boats what
is that Oh get out of there
how's it dude okay Jesus they snuck up
on the yay don't you yell at me they
probably saw my fire where's my where's
my hatchet where's my hatchet
please got the hatchet thank go okay so
hey hey you looking to steal my food I
don't want to fight these guys it's
actually not very fun to fight him they
take up for some reason I have a friggin
eye you want to fight huh let's just get
my food
goddamn in my phone you son of a [ __ ]
you get out of here you get out of here
with that noise also they make weird
jingling sounds no you can also climb up
into trees they're very they're very
agile and not very talkative don't you
dare yeah you run into that tree also
they have lamps on their head
I think they stole stuff yeah Santa the
fire yeah burn burn baby I'm gonna kill
this one while he's burning cuz he's
interrupted ah got him got him got him
got him okay he's not quite dead I have
to finish him off I think there we go
finished him off oh god he exploded into
body parts I don't think that was good
hey hey you want always done the fire
they're so dumb come here are you come
here are you yeah yeah what's up what's
up so so oh no you're dead and now
finish me off cuz sometimes I've had
them get up before that but I've never
had them explode into oh god that was a
lag I was holding that was a lovely
lovely leg well I know how to build
human effigies now I think that might
keep them away from me I'm not entirely
sure is that done yet
can I can I have my food how long does
it take to cook oh I'm covered in blood
I need to wash it off that's that's the
good thing about having this body of
water over here if I can just find it
again hey we're actually doing good I
managed to kill those two guys without
getting head because they walked into my
flames and they have this recoil thing
where if you hit them they'll bounce
back and they won't be able to react so
if they're on fire I guess I worked
really to my advantage okay so the plane
crash is where is it is that it over
there and that was just a patrol by the
way I didn't see any campsite so I don't
think that they're nearby but that was
just a patrol so I'm assuming that if I
kill both of them they're not gonna be
able to send their friends over to kill
me in retribution a there it is okay
then maybe I can get another fish wall
in here yeah I got one I'm getting good
I'm getting good so I'm assuming that I
managed to wash off the blood and those
bushes are weird I've noticed that those
bushes actually look like silhouettes of
people when they're in the background
because they go low resin it's hard to
tell exactly okay oh okay good I was
about to say I should be good I got fish
I got a source of food I got animals
animals everywhere just got to keep an
eye out for him it can be very easy to
miss things because like the iguanas
they just blend into the trees and the
rabbits are almost impossible to spot
unless you're on an open field I'm
actually lucky because as soon as I
started this game I managed to find one
that's amazing I've never been able to
do that before but either way you guys
are getting the idea that I am NOT
Oh total idiot asses do kind of know
what I'm doing right you guys guys guys
okay
what nope hi are you doing a topless
that's very inappropriate it's gonna
quit my hatchet right now hope you don't
mind uh so uh want to join me for some
dinner baby hello baby
no one can ignore the markiplier charms
what am i doing oh it's a bird but a
part of my hand and it pooped on my leg
but that's okay okay lady if you want to
become my forest wife I'm okay with that
you know uh maybe I could do a whole
Pocahontas thing here while you and I
get learned to love and then you got you
maybe convince him to give me my son
back then maybe well make another one
all the way he'll you know okay so i
I've never seen a friendly one of these
so oh he just didn't spot she just
didn't spot me so hi you gonna attack me
now you want to walk right through the
fire you wanna be a dumb-dumb hey come
on be a dum-dum for me come on baby I
bet you could be so dumb for me baby how
dumb can you be
will you go on them we go all don't run
away okay so it looks like she doesn't
want to fight which is totally fine with
me I'm assuming that she's gonna go get
reinforcements though so I need to go
build the next few things that I want to
build all right so you can also build
traps
happy birthday trap news trap I could
probably uh probably do that for some
rabbits but this happy birthday trap is
one of my favorites I don't even know
why actually I
I've never hadn't actually been able to
use this but I want actually one try
this oh my goodness what the hell what
how am I supposed to orient this I don't
know what I don't know I do not know the
way that I'm supposed to orient this I'm
gonna assume like I'm gonna put it out
here okay I can't place it can't place
it
well cannot place it well another egg
Hoonah
how do i okay hi again yeah I know lady
damn here thank you for that build it
right here so that you can get spiked I
think that's the right orientation once
again never been able to actually use
these so I don't know what the correct
orientation is I think I got these
sticks right here hey yo I can't him
anymore sticks yeah stick me oh hello
did you bring friends yet maybe for our
first date you would want to come over
here and just like say hi to me you know
maybe I could know your name first I
mean you're awfully beautiful and don't
get me wrong
love the whole aisle naturale look but
uh we need to get some communication
channels going on here before you and I
you know go any further I mean I just I
just fell out of the sky you know I'm
not even situated here my camp isn't
even real high oh okay you want you just
want to eat my food that's what you want
well I mean that's cool and all that's
cool you know hey sharing is caring
but at the same time uh there's not
really enough for me so if you could
just not dad be gray
haha happy birthday I almost stepped
right into that that would have been
horrible but hopefully they should be
able to prevent her from stepping in
this one spot in my open camp well I
mean is it not perfect I can actually
build walls around it though so that oh
good job trap you really got those
rabbits how do I reset it don't tell me
it's done do not tell me those rabbits
just ruined my happy birthday you son of
a [ __ ] you piece of ass rabbits what do
we do is it's just a defunct what's the
point of that okay later okay all right
all right yeah I was trying to be nice
I'll try to be nice by you I feel bad
about this but I can't have you ruining
up everything and come on just be quick
about it okay there we go I'm not gonna
dismember you yeah cuz that'd be gross
yeah do not want to see oh god why is
there an arm why didn't cut
forearm did I cut off her arm oh-o-oh on
the bile won't I eat that I don't eat
that
and I throw it I'm swinging an arm why
I'll be trying chopping down a tree with
an arm huh huh don't seem to be organ
huh let me block the marb
huh you need a hand there lady huh huh
okay there's plenty of jokes that give
all God it's even got long nails is
definitely our arm holding it by the
bone why hi
oh that's cool if I just hold it up wait
if I just have this out it automatically
breaks thing well that's so cool
probably a bug but geez look at that
thing go it's this clearing house
doesn't work this way for the axe this
is one crazy powerful harm I feel so I
feel so strong like nothing can stop me
well if I knew this power existed before
even started on this adventure I would
have come to this war as long ago yeah
good good good for me I can't wait to
see the terror on their faces when I
build the effigy taller than the mornin
okay so either way um I think that I am
done for this episode here I have
managed to screw up only a little bit
and I've actually got myself a good
start here so on this game is great it's
15 bucks on Steam it's early access so
if you get it now you'll get all the
updates for free I hope unless there's
something really douchey about that I
need some sleep so I'm gonna go take his
nappy nap with my arm my new best friend
the arm and all my birdie birdies they
love me that what oh look it's a little
birdy birdy al key for me you're
adorable
but either way I don't know what
happened with the food there okay so
either way I know there's a way to
extinguish that but either way this game
is incredibly fun if they had a
multiplayer feature to this game it
could be amazing for it because this is
what I wanted rust to be you know I
didn't want there to be like too much
involved with guns and holy crap these
birds give me a lot of feathers if I
find one needs feathers to be made I'm
gonna have a lot of them and a lot of
sticks to it
our mere so nobody where's my arm army
Amanda our man please come back to me
whose life read our manda where's my
wife I didn't kill my wife
here's her arm is proof Amanda Amanda
I lost our manda I don't know what
happened
hold on oh good arm and uh huh I thought
I lost you forever that you baby let me
check by the finger nose yeah it's you
our man that thought I lost you I like
I'm just carrying body parts in my
backpack but whatever I want you to
either way this game
I can't it's really fun you got to give
it a try it's worth it it's worth the
money go for it guys you won't regret it
so either way if you guys want me to ply
bar this game our mana did you get sassy
with me okay so you want me to play more
of this game please please let me know I
would I'm going to play this game on my
own but if you guys want me to make more
videos of it please let me know so
either way thank you all so much for
watching check out rust with Bob and
seven days to die
alright so seven days to die with Wayde
rust with Bob checking out kind of
similar games here
this is incredibly fun can't recommend
it more so thanks for watching let me
know if you want to see more and as
always I will see you in the next video
bye bye wave are manda
give me